migrants keep pouring over the border
and patrol agents fear they're bringing
more coven with them
the disease is surging at migrant
facilities with some 30 percent of ice
detainees
unvaccinated and refusing to get the
shots
despite this the new york post reports
that bus companies in mcallen texas
can't keep up with the demand
as overwhelmed border agents release
migrants into the u.s
meantime angry farmers and ranchers say
they want compensation for the damage
done to their property
fences gates uh uh some crop damage
uh other property damage uh you know
maybe vehicles that you know there's
there's vehicles that have been stolen
we feel like the the borders aren't
secure uh we feel like the
administration uh
could do more to help secure the borders
and and
basically we're saying that the property
damage is is coming because of the large
influx of of illegal immigrants
uh so with that being said uh we feel
like there needs to be some compensation
to uh
to property owners arizona republican
andy biggs is co-chair of the house
border security caucus congressman you
can put all of these
things together where you have 30
percent
of illegal immigrants in one area
refusing vaccination
people are being put on on buses
and sent into the the heartland and
other places in the country
and then you've got an administration
that maybe is ready to rep
roll back title 42 which would um
open the floodgates even more than they
already are
negan that's exactly right so title 42
for people who may not know what that is
that's the emergency uh authority to
refuse entry to people in a health
crisis that's just
a short way of putting it and these some
of these countries that folks are coming
from
are in a health crisis and you are at
seeing a massive increase in covid
uh spy in covid uh illness
coming from these folks and they don't
want to take the the
vaccination we get that but cbp can't
even the bus
border patrol agents they can't even uh
give
a test a rapid test of any kind because
they just are overwhelmed
so it's the ngos and in in the rio
grande valley
if they have if they have covet dagon
they're putting them up in hotels
and there's no these aren't detention
facilities these people can walk out
any time they want and they do and they
and they're there because they do have
code they test positive for covet
it is an unbelievable almost a surreal
situation
at the border every time i go down what
about the farmers demanding
payment essentially from the federal
government for the damage done to their
land do you think
that the biden companies step up to
compensate them
well they ought to because it's their
policies that are allowing
this uh surge this massive surge whether
it's in
uh southern california arizona new
mexico or texas
there is damage that's taking place
livestock being killed that
as as your as your uh video showed but i
mean the reality is
this administration gets what they want
and i would say that they've engaged in
a constructive taking by their policies
in other words they're they're allowing
the the ranchers and the farmers and the
businesses to have
damage done to them and municipalities
too by the way
because they haven't controlled the
border it's out of control
it's an invasion quite frankly well what
can the republicans do about it really
is becoming more
and more a state and local issue is it
not where you have
the governor of your home state and
texas and other places
that are really stepping up to try and
stop it because the people in charge in
washington the democrats
this is the way they want it
yeah this is the way they want it uh
democrats want it but but what we're
seeing and that this is a good move is
you've got county attorneys and some
attorneys general not all of them
that are actually bringing state charges
against these people it could be
criminal damage it could be trespass
that's where we have to that's where the
state and locals can get involved
in congress uh i'm we're trying to work
with some
special interest law firms they need to
file the same kinds of lawsuits that the
left filed against president trump when
he was in enacting policies
and they basically caused the 2019 surge
by stopping those policies
and the reality is these border patrol
agents the ice agents
you have members of congress that want
to defund them for pete's sakes and
eliminate them
and that's what we're facing in congress
but that's why it comes back to the
state and locals are really going to
have to step up
but so are these special interest law
firms meantime florida governor ron
desantis
is drawing some flack from the bidet
administration for declining to mandate
mass for kids
in school there's been talk about
potentially people advocating at the
federal level
imposing compulsory masks on kids
we're not doing that in florida okay we
need our kids to breathe
white house press secretary jen sake
then slammed the governor's decision
if i were a parent in florida that would
be greatly concerning to me
because kids under the age of 12 are not
vaccinated they're not eligible yet
we know masks are not the most
comfortable thing
i will say my kids are quite adjusted to
them as i know many kids are
so certainly we would have concern about
any step that doesn't abide by public
health guidelines
well we knew last year that children do
not contract covet as easily as adults
they don't spread it as easily as adults
and they don't get as sick
and even the 335 children under the age
of 18
who died with a covid diagnosis
the cdc still does not know
has not researched each death to figure
out whether covet actually
caused those deaths
yeah that's that's right dagon and so
under 18 the population is about 75
million americans
and every death is tragic for sure but
the the statistical
uh insignificance of 335 out of 75
million
cannot go unanswered and the cdc is not
recommending this
this is coming from the biden white
house dr fauci who's been wrong about
virtually everything
and the the reality is kids um
they don't spread as you said and they
don't tend to get this
as often as as adults do particularly
the
the senior citizen group so this is
another control type of aspect i think
and it's going to prevent
kids from being able to be normally just
i mean small
children in particular they develop by
being able to see facial reactions
linguistic development or language
development etc
so this is a real problem i i you know i
stand with with governor desantis i
think he's right i think governor
abbott's right
on this issue as well great to see you
andy biggs congressman thank you so much
have a great weekend
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now